i want to start with congrats on the
series uh first two episodes are great
um
i'm curious when you signed on when
marvel said to you hey we want you to do
this how much did they actually tell you
about the role and how much were you
sort of like marvel yeah i can do this
um
that's a good question
not very much to be honest with you
steve i mean
they did tell me
i mean that it was the swordsman
um and
basically that's it no i mean
certain things about the story that um
that you know i can't say right now
because it's part of the that's part of
the plot but they did say sort of where
the character
was kind of going
but not where it was going to end up um
not who anybody else was in it obviously
except for uh jeremy
but um
you know
i i talked to i talked with rhys for a
while about you know kind of the tone
that he wanted which is sort of this
sort of christmasy kind of
sort of light sort of and and and that
that was very appealing to me because um
you know i hadn't done something like
that in in a long time and and and also
we were right in the middle of the
pandemic uh you know pre-vaccination and
stuff so it was
it just it just fit in perfectly you
know
no completely um once you found out
you're playing swordsman uh who's been a
part of the comics for a very long time
um how much were you actually like
reading all the stuff you could get and
how much we sort of like well that's the
version that's come before i really just
got to stick with what's on the page
well i mean i did i did as much as i
could you know i um
you know bought a bunch of comic books
with uh with the swordsman just to get
an idea and also i mean the
the the character of jack duke kane when
he was created was
sort of loosely based on errol flynn
and i did want to have that sort of
essence so i did
i did my errol flynn research which uh
which is you know i think it's it's sort
of you can tell you can see it
i i wanted that sort of sort of that
sort of smiley guy that you don't know
if he's smiling for real because he
knows something or if he's just kind of
goofy or not
but but you know that he's good with the
sword you know you're not too sure about
him and then also i mean everything else
is just kind of there you know i mean
you have wreaths you have the scripts
you see how the set's working out and
you just kind of
you know you come with everything that
you can and then once it's there you you
just put it on the table and you see
what you can use and what you can't use
and and what comes you know
new to the character
um what surprised you actually about
making a marvel series that perhaps you
weren't like expecting going in
with the size the size of this thing man
i mean
just the sets the you know the the the
locations it was just like
wow okay this is humongous you know i
mean
there's there's like there's
some scenes there that we did in
rockefeller center that some summer's
just a set
i mean the rockefeller center set in
atlanta you know i mean
there was part that was done there but
other parts there wasn't so you just
show up there and there's a whole ice
skating rink there's a whole tree it's
you're in the middle of this humongous
you know sort of airs field there in
atlanta and it's like this is huge man
you know
i i can i've seen some i've been on some
marvel sets and i've seen the level of
detail of what they have the level of
detail yeah
it's it's crazy look before i run out of
time with you even though i have still a
little bit of time um i am a huge better
call saul fan i mean i love love the
series and i just want to know obviously
i know you can't say much but are you
allowed to tease anything about the
upcoming season uh what was it like
reading those scripts for the first time
it was very exciting man it was very
very exciting i mean
you have no idea what's going to happen
it's out of control what these guys
wrote out of control
i i'm so i'm so excited what is it like
for you though because you play
a very you're not really a nice guy on
the series let's say it like that what
is it like actually when you are in line
for starbucks or the supermarket and
people get a look at you is it you can
tell immediately i would imagine if
they're a fan of the show
well see the thing is that like i mean
by the time it came out we all wearing
masks so
nobody's nobody don't smell them
whatever
i mean it's it does happen like for
example
i got in last night um at the airport
and they make you take off your mask uh
at uh you know at the the the what's it
called the you know when you show up to
see the security checkpoint yeah and the
guy goes oh my god are you little
salamanca and i go yeah he goes oh my
god dude i love that show i was like
that okay there somebody recognized me
you know but otherwise you just got a
mask on all day so you know nobody's uh
it hasn't it hasn't kind of set in yet
uh mike going back to hawkeye uh my last
question for you um what are you
actually most excited for
fans to see in the series like what were
some you know what i mean like is was it
a
i guess what are you most excited for
people to say
i mean i think that just the fact of
getting jeremy back as as as clint is
is you know it's it's it's just it's
sort of like a warm fuzzy feeling for
for everybody who's you know been a fan
of avengers and of you know marvel
and also i mean
haley is really something else i mean
she's really unbelievable in this and i
think that she
really encaptures the whole
essence of you know the job at hand and
i think that people are going to love
that
yeah she's fantastic in the first two
episodes
yeah thank you so much for your time and
i really cannot wait for the upcoming
season of saul
so so excited thank you so much thank
you man take care